BUT I WANT TO WELCOME YOU ALL
TO THE MARCH TENTH HEARING. OF
THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE. TODAY WE HAVE FIVE
BILLS. THREE ARE ON CONSENT AS
A REMINDER WE LIMIT TESTIMONY
TO TWO WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND
EACH TWO MINUTES LONG ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES MAY ADD ON
BY STATING THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. IN ADDITION WE DO
HAVE. IF WE HAVEN'T COMPLETED
OUR HEARING BY ONE FORTY FIVE
WE WILL RECESS THE HEARING SO
THAT MEMBERS MAY TEND THE STATE
JUDICIARY ADDRESS AND WE WILL
RE CONVICT CAN RECONVENE OUR
HEARING UPON COMPLETION. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWO ZERO TWO
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN
HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
ON ITEM NUMBER SIX AB. TWO ZERO
EIGHT SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY I AM
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHTY SIX LEGISLATION
SUPPORTING OUR SOCIAL WORKERS
IN THE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY R.
F. F. A SYSTEM FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
EVER PHASE OUR PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE AGENCIES THAT ARE USED
BY COUNTY PLACING DEPARTMENTS
FOR CHILDREN WHO REQUIRE MORE
INTENSIVE CARE THAN A TYPICAL
FAST. OF FOSTER FAMILY HOME.
EVER OF AIDS RECRUIT CERTIFY
APPROVED TRAINING PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL SUPPORT TO FOSTER
PARENTS IN RESOURCE FAMILIES.
THERE ARE ALSO REQUIRED TO MAKE
AVAILABLE A CORE SET OF
SERVICES TO DEPENDENT CHILDREN
INCLUDING SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. WORKERS IN THE
FFA SYSTEM SERVE ALMOST
THIRTEEN THOUSAND FOSTER YOUTH
ACCOUNTING FOR ONE THIRD OF ALL
FOSTER YOUTH IN HOME BASED CARE
IN CALIFORNIA. OTHER THAN
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PROGRAM FUNDED BY REALIGNMENT
THE FFA RATE AND THE INFANT
SUPPLEMENTS ARE THE ONLY
SECTIONS WITHIN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM THAT DO NOT HAVE AN
AUTOMATIC ANNUAL COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS OR COLA. IN
ADDITION TO HARMING THE WORK
FORCE BY CREATING ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES THE LACK OF A COLA
HAS A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOU
THEMSELVES. EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CASEY FAMILY PROGRAMS
STUDY REPORTED THAT AN OPTIMAL
SOCIAL WORK- TURNOVER RATE IS
BELOW TWELVE PERCENT. CHILD
WHILE FOR SOCIAL WORKERS
EMPLOYED BY NONPROFIT FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES EXPERIENCE A
59% TURNOVER RATE OVER A PERIOD-OF UP TO YEARS. RESEARCH ALSO
SHOWS THAT WHEN SOCIAL WORKERS
TURN OVER AT A HIGH RATE THE
FOSTER YOUTH THEY SERVE HAVE A
LOWER CHANCE OF ACHIEVING
PERMANENCY AND SPECIFIC
SETTINGS. THE PRIMARY FACTOR
DRIVING THIS HIGH TURNOVER RATE
IS THE FAA'S INABILITY TO PAY
COMPETITIVE SALARIES. DUE TO
THE STATE SETTING THAT PAY RATE
FOR EFFORT FACED SOCIAL WORKERS
AT LEVELS FAR BELOW WHAT IS
NEEDED TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
THEM. CONSIDERING THAT 80% OF
THIS WORKFORCE IDENTIFY AS
FEMALE THIS DISCREPANCY CREATES
A SERIES GENDER EQUITY ISSUE AS
WELL. AB TWENTY EIGHTY SIX WILL
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BY
REQUIRING AN ANNUAL STATE
APPROVED COLTTE TO REMAIN IN
EFFECT IN THE F. OF A RATE. THE
COLA WILL STAY IN EFFECT UNTIL
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES PRESENTS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW TO ENSURE
THE FFA SOCIAL WORKERS WILL BE
ADEQUATELY COMPENSATED IN ORDER
TO IMPROVE RETENTION OF CHILD
WELL FIRST SOCIAL WORKERS TO
IMPROVE PERMAN PERMANENCY
OUTCOMES. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY. SHORT TESTIMONY I'M
NOT OUT TO TESTIFY I HAVE
REBEKAH GONZALEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS. AND LORA HINES WITH
STEM FOR YOUTH SOLUTIONS AND
SIERRA FOREVER FAMILIES. BEFORE
WE TAKE TESTIMONY I'D LIKE TO
STEPS QUORUM PLEASE. RAMOS.
MATHIS HERE ARAMBULA CHOI
FRIEDMAN GIPSON MAIENSCHEIN
STONE. THANK YOU THE. I GET
YOUR FIRST AND SECOND- FIRST
WITNESS PLACE HELLO MY NAME IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ AND I'M WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE REPRESENT TEN
THOUSAND SOCIAL WORKERS WITH
THEIR DEGREE FROM AN ACCREDITED
SCHOOL OF SOCIAL WORK WE WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR SPONSORING THAT SPELL-
SOCIAL SOCIAL WORKERS WHO WORK
IN THESE AGENCIES ARE HIGHLY
EDUCATED THEY ALL HAVE THEIR
MASTER'S DEGREE WELL THEY WERE
GETTING THEIR DEGREE THEY WERE
I AM REQUIRED TO GET BETWEEN
NINE HUNDRED AND TWELVE HOUR I
TWELVE HUNDRED INTERNSHIP HOURS
WHICH IS. TWO TO THREE DAYS A
WEEK DURING THEIR MASTER'S
PROGRAM WHERE THEY ARE IN
AGENCIES LEARNING- HOW TO WORK
WITHIN THOSE AGENCIES SO IT'S
VERY- IT'S A VERY STRENUOUS
IT'S A VERY RIGOROUS PROGRAM-
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED THE
MAJORITY OF THE SOCIAL WORKERS
ARE WOMEN AND COME FROM MANY
COME FROM COMMUNITIES OF COLOR-
STUDENTS WHO ENTER THE SOCIAL
WORK FASHION ARE OFTEN FROM
COMMUNITIES OF POVERTY
THEMSELVES AND MANY FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH ARE INSPIRED TO GO
INTO THE SOCIAL WORK.
PROFESSION ONCE WORKING SOCIAL
WORKERS- ARE OFTEN SUPPORTING
FAIR THEIR OWN FAMILIES WHILE
THEY'RE PAYING BACK THEIR
STUDENT LOANS- THIS FORCES THEM
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN A JOB THEY
MAY LIVE. AND TO SUPPORTING
THEIR OWN FAMILIES IN ADDITION
THESE CHILDREN OFTEN OFTEN
BECOME ATTACHED TO THEIR SOCIAL
WORKER AND TURNOVER IS
TRAUMATIZING TO THESE YOUTH-
AND AS WE KNOW THIS OFTEN
RESULTS IN LOWER PERMANENCY
OUTCOMES. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU TERRY
MEMBERS PLEASE THANK YOU- FIRST
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO FOR ENERGY SAYING THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS DOCTOR LAURA
HEIGHTS ON THE CEO STANFORD YOU
SOLUTIONS NOW KNOWN AS STANFORD
SIERRA YOUTH AND FAMILIES. I'M
ALSO THE BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE. US
STANFORD TERRACE SERVES OVER
FOUR THOUSAND YOUTH AND
FAMILIES IN THE SACRAMENTO
REGION AND WE PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SCHOOL SERVICES
JUVENILE JUSTICE. ADOPTION AND
WE ARE A FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
WE PROVIDE INTENSIVE SERVICES
OSTER HOMES AND FOSTER HOMES
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN.
DISPLACED MULTIPLE TIMES AND
ARE DEEMED HARD TO PLACE AND
HOMES SOCIAL WORKERS WHO WORK
IN AT THE FACE HAVE MASTERS
LEVELS THAT EDUCATION AND
SOCIAL WORK. OR A RELATED FIELD
AND THEY SERVE ON CALL TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN. TO PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALIZED US THERAPEUTIC
SUPPORT SERVICES TO THEIR YOUNG
PEOPLE AND FAMILIES. WE ARE
UNABLE TO ADEQUATELY PAY OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS AND ADJUST THEIR
PAY FOR COST OF LIVING
INCREASES. AND WHEN THAT
HAPPENS OUR SOCIAL WORKERS MUST
LEAVE WE FACED A 100% TURNOVER
IN OUR TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND
HE SAID THOUSAND SIXTEEN YEARS.
AND WE CONTINUE TO FACE A HIGH
TURNOVER RATE HOWEVER THE COLA
OF FOUR POINT 15% IN NINETEEN
TWENTY. A HELP TO SLOW THAT
TURNOVER SO WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. WE HAVE NO MECHANISM TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL SALARY INCREASES AT
THIS POINT THE REASON THAT
RETENTION IS SO IMPORTANT IS
THAT EVERY TIME OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS LEAVE. THE PERMANENCY
PROGRESS FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
IS STALLED AND THE STABILITY OF
THE PLACEMENT IN THE FOSTER
HOME IS ALSO COMPROMISED. YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE STRUGGLE WITH
THE LOSS OF THE SOCIAL WORKER
AS IT HAS A COMPOUNDING EFFECT
ON THEM DUE TO THEIR PAST
TRAUMA. FOSTER PARENTS NUMBER
ONE COMPLAINT AND- IS TURNOVER
OF THEIR FOSTER CARE SOCIAL
WORKER WHO IS THEIR PRIMARY
SUPPORT. I ASKED THAT THE STATE
PRIORITIZE ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR
OUR FFA IS. FIRST OF ALL IF IT
PAYS ARE CRITICAL IN THE
CONTINUE OF CARE REFORM. FOSTER
YOUTH NEED STABILITY AND THEIR
CARE TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
ACHIEVE PERMANENCY AND
PERMANENCY IS WHERE WE FIND THE
TRUE COST SAVINGS FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ON AB TWENTY
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE. HI THIS IS HIS AN
INDEFINITE CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CAN LUIS
REPRESENTING AT ANNETTE AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LAURA RICHARDSON QUEEN ANNE OF
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. JACKIE RESIZER WITH
A CALIFORNIA LINES OF JOHN THE
FAMILY SERVICES CO SPONSOR THE
BILL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
DILLON WE SANTI WITH LILY PUT
FAMILIES FOSTER CARE AGENCY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. VERY
GOOD LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ON MISTER MATHIS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR. ARE YOU ACCEPT
DEAN- CO AUTHORS ARE JOINT
AUTHORS ON THIS ABSOLUTELY
WOULD LOVE TO JOINT AUTHORED
THIS WITH YOUR SHOW BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ABSOLUTELY WE NEED ALL
THE HELP THAT WE CAN GET THIS
IS A CRITICAL ISSUE FOR FOSTER
YOUTH AND SO ANY HELP. WILL BE
WELCOME ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
MR GIPSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR- I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR I
THINK IT'S A GREAT BILL. I
THINK THAT AGAIN- SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS IN A LOT OF SENSE-
CERTAINLY TO BE COMPENSATED WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO ALLOW- THIS-
CAREER CHOICE- TO DWINDLE- WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROMOTE THIS AND ALSO TRY TO
GET PEOPLE INTO THIS
PROFESSION. BECAUSE THESE ARE
THE FRONTLINE INDIVIDUALS GOING
TO CARE FOR OUR CHILDREN-
MOVING FORWARD AND SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THIS PROFESSION.
IS TAKEN WAS TAKEN CARE OF AND
ALSO- CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR. THEM TO CREATE A
LIFESTYLE- BY PROVIDING THE
KIND OF SERVICE THEY PROVIDE
BUT ALSO MAKE SURE TO GO HUNGRY
AT THE SAME TIME WITH THE
CONSULATE IN CALIFORNIA THINGS
OF THAT NATURE SO. I'VE ONE
SUPPORTED AND WILL GLADLY LOVE
TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. CHOI THANKS CHAIR
THIS MUST BE VERY POPULAR OF
BILL IF YOU HAVE A ROOM- ADD ME
ALSO IT'S- THIS IS THE FIRST. I
WONDER IF- SORCERER- WORK
REQUIRES A MASTERS TO VIA IN
COMPARISON TO OTHER-
OCCUPATION- OF COMPARABLE ORDER
IN EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS SO.
IT IT IS IT- EACH QUARTER TO OR
THE OCCUPATION PAY THIS A C. P.
R. INCREASES A BASIC ANY OTHER
IN OCCUPATION OR HALF OF SALARY
INCREASE AT ON A WIDE THIS HAS
NOT BEEN TAKING PLACE. IF YOU
WANT I MEAN AT THE END GENERAL
SOCIAL WORKERS WITH THE AND A
MASTER'S DEGREE MAKE MUCH LESS
THAN OTHER PROFESSIONS WHERE
YOU HAVE THAT LEVEL OF
EDUCATION THEY GOING TO SOCIAL
WORK BECAUSE THEY WANT TO HELP
PEOPLE- THEY HAVE A DEEP DESIRE
TO HELP THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THEY KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE
SOME SACRIFICES BY CHOOSING
THIS CAREER. BUT THIS
PARTICULAR AREA OF SOCIAL WORK
WORKING IN FF PHASE IS LOWER
COMPARED TO EIGHTY EVEN THE
OTHER PLACES YOU COULD GO TO IN
SOCIAL WORK SO FFA IS LOSE
THEIR WORKERS TO OTHER AREAS OF
SOCIAL WORK. YEAH BECAUSE WHAT
I'M WORRIED THESE THAT THAT
THIS IS A BASIC OF COLA
INCREASE IS NOT GONNA CATCH UP
WITH THE IF THIS OF ADMITTED
DISCREPANCY HOW WE CAN RAISE IN
THE EQUAL LEVEL. I THINK THAT
SAYS SOMETHING FOR ME AS AN ART
SOMEWHERE AND I THINK THIS IS
WHAT THE BEGINNING IS AND JUST-
AS A FORMER TEACHER R. I'M SO
CURRENT A TEACHER- JUST IN
COMPARISON AS A TEACHER YOU CAN
START TEACHING WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. AND YOU GET
PAID MORE IF YOU GET A MASTER'S
DEGREE AS OPPOSED TO STARTING
AS A MASTER'S DEGREE AND NOT
MAKING YOU KNOW ADEQUATE
COMPENSATION FOR IT AND YOU
KNOW YES STOP THROUGH TEACHING
THEY'LL- THE B. CTA. THE
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS IS A AND HAS BUILT IN-
YOU KNOW A REGULAR COLA OR AT
LEAST THE QUOTATIONS AND THAT'S
NOT TRUE IN THIS CASE.
ESPECIALLY THIS OF SOCIAL
WORKERS TEND TO WORK ON A VERY
EMOTIONALLY I HAD TO THE
TRAINING KIND OF WORK I SAW A
THING OF THE A COMPENSATION
APARTMENT SHOULD BE BROUGHT UP.
FOR SOME. THANK YOU YOU AGREE.
VERY GOOD ALL WE HAVE A AND I
WANT TO THANK IS GOING TO FROM
HERE ALSO. FROM THE CULT AN
AREA THANK YOU YES MAYES RUBIO
FROM BRING MINE YEAH SHE LOOKED
FAMILIAR. SELECT A LONG TIME
AGO BUT RIGHT TO CLAIM HER. ALL
RIGHT IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL I THINK THAT- THERE WAS AN
EFFORT LAST YEAR SO THERE WAS A
ONE TIME INCREASE AND I'M GLAD
THAT WAS CLARIFIED THAT WE
DON'T LOSE THAT. BUT HAVING
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
DOCTOR CHOI YOU'RE CORRECT- IT
SHOULD BE SO MUCH MORE. WE
AREN'T THERE BUT IN THE VERY
LEAST MS RUBIO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD YOUR FIRST MOTION BY
MISTER MATHIS- SECONDED BY
MISTER STONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH THINKING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THE
MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RAY S. I RAMOS I AM
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN ICE
STONE. STONE HI. SEVEN VOTES
IT'LL BE OUT WE CAN HOLD IT
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
CAN WE TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MADAM CHAIR I
MOVE ON THE CONNECTS THAT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE MOTION BY MS
FRIEDMAN. SECOND BY MISTER
GIBSON. THE MOTION FOR. TARGET
TAKE THE ROOM MAKING. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR RAMOS HI RES I
MATHIS MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA.
CHOI AYE CHU AYE AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON GIPSON I'D
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
STONE. STONE I. WILL LEAVE THE
RECORD OPEN ALSO FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ABSENT MEMBER. THESE
AND OTHER BILLS. THEIR OWN
OPPOSITION RIGHT NOW. SURE. BUT
LOOK.
ALL RIGHT MISS FRIEDMAN
IS GOING TO PRESENT ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE ON AB TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN OKAY THINK THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TODAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT INSTEAD OF ME
READING THIS WHY DON'T WE JUST
GO RIGHT TO THE WITNESSES VERY
GOOD FIRST WITH THIS PLACE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
BERRY JUTTING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION HERE- TO PRESENT
AND PRODUCT A SPONSOR AB TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN. THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY
CHANGE THE MECHANISM WE USE FOR
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES WHEN
THIS WHEN THE STATE MINIMUM
WAGE GOES UP FOR PROVIDERS OF
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. THE
CURRENT MECHANISM IS BACKWARD
LOOKING HISTORICAL IT ONLY
PROVIDES- INCREASES FOR.
WRITERS WHO HAVE OF FOLKS
UNDERNEATH THE NEW MINIMUM WAGE
THRESHOLD. UNFORTUNATE THIS
LEAVE THAT A LOT OF THE HIGH
COST AREAS OF THE STATE AND
EVEN IN OTHER AREAS OF THE
STATE WE ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP
UP WITH WAGE GROWTH AND
COMPETITIVE MARKET PLACES. AND
WE CAN'T EVEN PAY OUR STAFF
EVEN IN LOWER COST AREAS
MINIMUM WAGE FOR GOING TO BE
COMPETITIVE THESE ARE PEOPLE
PROVIDE SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS. WITH DISABILITIES
THEY DON'T DESERVE TO BE
MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYEES IN THE
FIRST PLACE- BUT THIS NEW PUT
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD AT LEAST
ADDRESS SOME RATE RELIEF WITH A
THREE POINT 33% AUTOMATIC
PASSED THROUGH. THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO PAY OUR STAFF MORE
AS THE MINIMUM WAGE GOES UP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I DO
WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT WE HAD
ABOUT THREE MOTIONS. AND SIX
SECONDS BUT- OUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS EDWARD HERSHEY
ON THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
OPERATIONS FOR HOME OF GUIDING
HANDS. A SERVICE PROVIDER IN
SAN DIEGO THAT PROVIDE SERVICES
TO OVER THIRTY NINE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I'M ALSO A PARENT OF A YOUNG
WOMAN THAT RECEIVE SERVICES
FROM THE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL
CENTER. AS A PROVIDER THE
MINIMUM WAGE CORK AS DESCRIBED
BY THE LA- HAS HAD A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON MY
ORGANIZATION. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
THIRTY NINE OPEN DIRECT SERVICE
PROVIDER POSITIONS THAT
TRANSLATES TO THIRTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS A WEEK. THAT WE STRUGGLE
TO PROVIDE FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED SERVICES.
AS WITH MANY OF THE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IN OUR INDUSTRY
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT TO
TURN OVER. THAT IMPACTS OUR
ABILITY TO OFFER CONSISTENT
SERVICES FOR THE INDIVIDUALS WE
SERVE. TO HIGHLIGHT THIS IMPACT
I WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY. OPPORTUNITY TO
TELL YOU A STORY ABOUT MY
DAUGHTER JULIA. JULIE IS TWENTY
FOUR YEARS OLD LIKE MANY TWENTY
FOUR YEAR OLD SHE LOVES TO
DANCE SHE LOVES TO SING. SHE
LOVES TO HANG OUT WITH HER
FRIENDS AND SHE HAS
UNCONDITIONAL LOVE FOR EVERYONE
SHE MEETS. THAT LAST PART MIGHT
NOT BE EVERYBODY BUT IT DOES
DESCRIBE MY DAUGHTER JULIA. IN
ADDITION SHE ALSO HAS WILLIAM
CENTRO. HER GOAL IN LIFE IS TO
MOVE OUT ON HER OWN AND WITH
THE SUPPORT OF HER DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDER SHE WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL ONE DAY AND THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS SHE HAS HAD TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TURN OVER IN HER
SUPPORT. SHE'S HAD THREE CASE
WORKERS IN TWO YEARS SHE'S HAD
FOR DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS IN
TWO YEARS. NOW YOU CAN IMAGINE
SHE HASN'T BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
REACHING HER GOAL TO MOVE OUT.
IN FACT AT THIS POINT SHE TAKES
IT PERSONALLY SHE BELIEVES THAT
THEY'RE LEAVING HER. BECAUSE
SHE'S DONE SOMETHING WRONG. SO
AND NOW INSTEAD OF REACHING HER
GOAL OF MOVING OUT SHE'S
WORKING ON COUNSELING TO HELP
SUPPORT HER WITH THAT LOSS.
RECENTLY THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT OUTCOMES AND
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
AS A PARENT AND A PROVIDER I AM
IN FULL SUPPORT OF PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVES HEARING JULIA STORY
HOW WOULD YOU MEASURE SUCCESS.
IN RELATIONSHIP TO HER OUTCOMES
IS IT THE FAULT OF THE
PROVIDERS THAT SHE'S NOT
SUCCESSFUL IS IT THE FAULT OF
THE REGIONAL CENTER THAT SHE'S
NOT SUCCESSFUL. TO THE FAILURE
TO MEET JULIUS OUT COME FALL.
TO THE REGIONAL CENTER OR THE
PROVIDERS HOW CAN WE EXPECT TO
REACH. PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES
AND TELL THE SYSTEM IS STABLE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN'S BILL AB
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR HELPS TO
PROVIDE THE STABILITY IT
ESTABLISHES IN LAW. A WELL
REASONED CONNECTION BETWEEN
INCREASES IN STATE MINIMUM WAGE
AND THE COST INCREASES THEY
CREATE IN PROVIDING SERVICES
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. IT THEN MAKES THE
APPROPRIATE RATE ADJUSTMENTS
UNIFORMLY AND STATEWIDE IN
CLOSING I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. A
DOCTOR MOTION BY DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
STORY FOUNDER FOR BEING THERE
EVEN THOUGH SHE'S HAD THE TURN
OVER SHE'S GOT YOU THE
STABILITY. CORRECT AND AS A
PROFESSIONAL IN THIS INDUSTRY
THE STRUGGLE I FACED- YOU CAN
IMAGINE PEOPLE THAT AREN'T IN
THE INDUSTRY THAT THAT'S
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST SURPRISE.
WE CAN ONLY IMAGINE. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WHAT WITH
THE- THANK YOU. MIKE I DON'T
THINK THE MIKE IS ON. MAYBE IT
IS. WOULD BE FANTASTIC ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE IN THE
NATION. OR HAVE THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS KAREN JANE HERE ON
BEHALF OF J. PACK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ROLLINS REPRESENTED
ARCA SO SHE XIN REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MEMBERS JORDAN
LINDSAY WITH YOUR KING ON ITS
RIPPLES A CALIFORNIA COUPLE
COLLABORATION AND ON THE LIMóN
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORTER
THIS AND THANK YOU TO MISTER
HOLD FOR CARRYING AND SO MANY
OF YOU FOR BEING SO STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF CALIFORNIA'S WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU. AND CHAIR MEMBERS
ROXANNE GOLD REPREENTING SIX
BEDS IT'S THE ASSOCIATION OF
SMALL SIX BEDS ARE FEWER.
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON BRING
UP BROWN'S KIßM WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH SERVICES AT HOME STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS. THANK YOU. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS. MR MATHIS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I WAS GONNA ASK THE
AUTHOR TO BE JOINED WITH HIM ON
THIS- BUT HE'S NOT HERE BUT I'M
SURE HE'D APPRECIATE THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT- SIR I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- I HAVE CHILDREN THAT
ARE IN THE SYSTEM AND I KNOW
pDEFINITELY DAYS WHERE YOU BANG
YOUR HEAD AGAINST THE WALL AND
I SEE HER AS A MEMBER GOING IF
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THIS WHAT
ABOUT EVERYBODY ELSE WHO
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND HOW THE
SYSTEM WORKS SHE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THE RESOURCES GO
THROUGH. SO WHY ON THERE WITH
YA AND WE NEED TO DO A HELL OF
A LOT MORE. CHAU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS. SEEING
NO OTHER- COMMENTS- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AND I URGE AND
I'VE OF. THANK YOU. FOR MOTION
BY MISTER STONE SECOND BY
MISTER MATHIS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE RAMOS
HI RES I MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
ARAMBULA. CHOI CHOICE HI
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I'D
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE STONE HI.
THANK. YEAH THAT'S SEVEN ZERO
THE ROLE WILL BE PEN FOR FIVE
MINUTES FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
HOUSE I BELIEVE. OKAY. OKAY
HERE. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I FINAL VOTE EIGHT TWO
ZERO. FILE ITEM THREE AB TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR CURRENT VOTE SEVEN
TO ZERO ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
FINAL VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO. FILE
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY EIGHTY SIX
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO
ARAMBULA REGULAR AYE FINAL VOTE
EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER
RAMGOOLAM. ALL RIGHT THAT
CONCLUDES OUR HUMAN SERVICES
HEARING.